[Music]
i don't even know if this song is in
tune
i don't even know if sam's strings are
being bent
to be in tune it doesn't really matter
cause
we're gonna light up the moon
[Music]
that's why we don't make music as a
profession
because we make videos instead
[Music]
okay that's enough this isn't in tune
this is
i just grabbed this off the wall i
haven't played these in like months i
told you to tune it before we started
nico turn off that horrid noise
reduction
this guy is like okay god i mean
you mean turn on that excellent noise
reduction is what you meant to say
yeah i like how guys if you're still
here after a minute and a half
thank you uh we like to intro these real
janky
that way we make sure only the troutons
are here with us
everybody else listening is like
watch them out yeah we get rid of them
early we make our stuff purposefully bad
to give people
only the truest of fans will still enjoy
it
yeah oh man wow real quick speaking
speaking of instruments
um so i discovered that there's a master
handpan craftsman
here in glendale california literally
three minutes from my house are you
gonna go
of course i'm gonna get it i actually i
went and visited this morning i made an
appointment at 9 30 a.m
and met with him and learned a little
bit about my handpan
as well as the stuff he makes it's uh
his place is called he has two companies
basically he has acolyte instruments
which is
hand pans for the for the average
consumer like you and me
and kids for the average man's hands
exactly
and then he has uh his custom hand
panned uh
shop called nirvana handpan where he
will custom make a hand pan
in whatever tuning you want um and all
these different like
materials and he only makes 24 a year
so yeah i'm signing up i won't get
myself
certainly yeah hand pants or pan of
man's hands
that's for sure yeah these handmade hand
pans are going to be making my hands
real sore man he's probably got like
hands of steel he's got some thick
slappers
yeah from his pan and all those pants
and just
hand in all those pants giant calluses
making his webbed fingers just super
thick
when you look at his when you look at
his hand sideways it actually looks like
there's another hand on it because it's
just
it's just
wait wait we're not done with this
you're getting one nico
i am gonna get one i'm i'm putting in my
deposit here
so i can be in line and i won't get
until march maybe maybe you'll hear this
podcast
or maybe i don't maybe somebody in this
workshop is a fan of corridor and
they're like
hey nico ordered a handpan and maybe
he'll bump it up
the line what tuning what tuning
he knows that's a good question so i
wasn't sure how good i wasn't sure how
good my handpan was so i brought it in
he's like
it's not bad i was like cool um
but i was like you know maybe she gets
something that could complement this
he's like you know what
you're gonna drop the money to get a
really nice hand pan
don't get it in like some like other
obscure key
get it in your main key that you're
working in and you know what if you want
to get another companion piece just sell
this one on craigslist that you already
got this you know that's the older one
you got and you can get another one that
way but
he's like you're gonna play the the new
one the most so make that one
the one you're most familiar with so i'm
gonna probably stick with a d minor here
i might get a slightly different version
of the d minor scale
um but yeah that's what that's what i'm
thinking it sounds like a true master
speaking
yeah yeah straight up it's pretty cool
like these are really obscure
instruments they were invented like the
instrument was literally invented in the
year 2000
and it wasn't really available for like
more than one person for like the next
decade and to get one was like
you have to be like 10 grand for one and
a little by little people figured out
how to make them
and it's kind of spread and this guy's
been making him by hand for about
six years he's probably made more hand
pans than like
you know he's probably like in the top
10 people in the world that have made
hand pans
that's the beauty of los angeles you
know it's like you have all these crazy
people here that do amazing things
he's the handpan man he's the handpan
man
he makes pains he's got hands together
can i ask a question though no if this
instrument has only been around
since 2000 mm-hmm
well it's a take on like a [ __ ] uh like
sorry a jamaican like steel drum kind of
right yes
similar similar in in inspiration
that's i mean that's actually where it
came from it was a it was a swedish dude
i think who was uh
swisher swedish i think it's swedish um
person who had gone
and had like a residency in jamaica
learning how to make steel drums for a
while
and they came back to sweden of course
like the whole like european pretentious
thing it's like i make sound sculptures
so i made an inverted steel drum and
they're like whoa this is actually super
cool and sounds really neat
and uh you know you had to write them an
essay for them to make you
an instrument those guys so
yeah needless to say like wait other
people yeah
they made you prove that you had what it
takes
for them to make a hand pant for you to
be fair you know it's like one dude like
a craftsman spending like a week working
on it
so they want to make sure like they're
not just give it to some like person
who's gonna
not ever ever play it but you know it
still is a bit uh gatekeeping
so other people learned how to make them
eventually the american in me is like
why wouldn't you just ask more money
until until you establish a market that
pays for the amount
for the price that suits the rate at
which you can make them
they did i think it was all part of the
mystique oh the exclusivity because they
still charge 10 grand
okay yeah okay now you can get one like
you know you can get one from this guy
they like the acolyte instruments one
like where it's just they're
they're the ones that are like are made
at a certain key and they just mass
produces those i mean quote unquote mass
produces aka three dudes just work on
them in a workshop
um but you can get those for twelve
hundred dollars versus you know back in
the day
okay costing five to ten okay i only
have one more question
and then we can move on from hand pans
yes
how do you become a master handpan
man as in like how does this guy become
a master craftsman or how do you become
a good
musician you said he was a master
handpan man
i think you'd become a master handpan
man by making
hundreds of handpans by hand in your
workshop
okay yeah okay okay
there wasn't like some musical board
that no there's not like a guy at the
black belt who like charges it
you know challenges you to a duel and
then you can like it's like you know
it's like a banjo duel because he
banjo masters have to kill another banjo
master to
retake and then and then you have to
play the devil right exactly yeah
yeah because every banjo master has
defeated the devil on a banjo duel yeah
yeah that's why there's only
two of them yeah it's like uh
what's his name uh earl there's uh
earl scruggs there's little
and uh i can't believe i'm forgetting i
can't believe i'm blanking on his name
anyways this is unforgivable they're out
there
it's fine no the guy that invented the
three-picking banjo
no one knows his name oh my god i have
to remember this
guys i'm sorry i failed you all i don't
remember his name
it's the guy that used to accompany
scruggs
it's not like you're on a computer
boy if only somebody made a search
engine first pick up these things
scruggs and flat
flat ah yes lester flat and earl scruggs
there you go how could you forget
anyways
so uh the election happened but we're
recording this before it's uh officially
happened
yes um on election night at the moment
that we're
recording this yeah this is now a relic
we have no idea who's going to win
maybe when it comes out people will
still have no idea
yeah i have a feeling it's going to be
well here let's take predictions here
okay actually let me just also say one
more thing i'd love to talk about
something more after our predictions
yeah people generally know that we avoid
politics at corridor
because we're not a political we don't
there's a lot of
baggage that comes with starting to like
take political stances on things that
doesn't mean we don't
share our philosophies right but we tend
to not like endorse people so
this prediction around here is not us
endorsing anything
who do you predict is gonna win what do
you predict is gonna happen
um i'll i guess i'm starting uh
i i think biden's gonna win
but it's really hard to say because
everyone thought that in 2016
too everyone thought that clinton was
gonna win
and uh she didn't obviously
obviously yeah so
you know i it's hard for me to say for
sure um
because you're gonna give an answer you
gotta give it fast because everyone
listening is just shaking their heads
going they all know they don't know
everyone knows the answer they already
know okay yeah that's my answer
that's my answer you already know who
won
i think biden's gonna win but i think
it's gonna be by a slim margin
um and my instincts could be wrong
because everyone was wrong in 2016
about that too i have to agree i have to
agree
i think it's be pretty tight but biden's
probably gonna win because
um i just feel like all the people who
are amped about trump in 2016
have been basically [ __ ] on for the last
four years so i feel like
i don't think he's gained more
supporters so to speak
by the way sam your voice sounds like a
robot it does sound a little bit like a
robot
did that just wait wait wait it just
happened how about now
now you're just quiet okay well
it's a little better okay well
is your phone near your microphone no
well now that we're mid podcast
now you're really quiet now you're a
quiet robot
so what i can play tech support here
but it's a gamble this is just cut this
out of the episode no we don't cut
anything from the episodes anymore this
is
you're we're here to hang out you're
flying along on the top of a train
and the little choo-choo bell isn't
working anymore and you got to fix it at
100 miles an hour
try unplugging your microphone and
plugging it back in uh
it's it's a xlr microphone so if i
unplug the interface
i have to i think your interface is what
messed up honestly
i'm getting that i'm getting that that
garbledness that there we go we're
cutting this out of the episode
it's cutting my audio
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen dobie made a guest
appearance in the podcast just anyways
sam we're leaving this in we're leaving
all this in it's great okay well it's
okay we're just hitting that
flush on the toilet right now as we're
just trying to flush as many listeners
off this podcast as possible
all right and now the podcast begins
here we go
all right sam who are you predicting
yeah no i think it's i think this could
be biden but
close margin i personally think he's
lost more supporters than gained
um but i mean i don't know neither
outcome isn't necessarily ideal
uh unfortunately you think trump's lost
more supporters than gained
that's what you're saying yeah i don't
know if that's true or not because with
the
with with the everything that's gone on
this year i don't know
honestly it's it's really hard to say it
it might be just a wash
like people may have left people may
have joined but i don't know
i'm big into statistics i really enjoy
like the day before an election and
reading all the statistics
i've looked at some pretty good
breakdowns and the thing with with
the 2016 election is that you know you
have a you have a basically
usually for your polls you have a
three-point margin of error that can go
in one direction or the other
so if you're at zero you can either
swing you know towards negative three
you can swing to positive three which
really means you have a six percent or a
six point
you know swinging which is deviation
actually yeah yeah
and so uh hillary was you know while
they projected her to win her favorite
her to win
um if you picked you know if you went
into the
towards trump's favor for that
three-point deviation then trump wins
and once again you can totally be within
that margin like anywhere within that
margin is fine it's not like it's any
less likely to occur
in one candidate's favor than another
and that's something that wasn't really
communicated to people when like when
they're doing the news broadcast and
stuff is that like
hillary was only fair to win within the
three-point margin and if you know and
if that three-point margin was an error
in favor of trump then
trump was going to win and that's what
happened currently
that's not the case you know currently
biden is
favored to win you know and if it goes
all the way towards
trump's margin of error biden is still
likely to win but it's just going to be
a narrow victory versus landslide
victory
and my computer screen just disappeared
yeah it's it's hard to say if those
polls are
have have accuracy if they're accurate
too because you know just from the
the climate this year like it's very
clear that a lot of people left leaning
voted early
a lot of people right leaning voted to
today
and a lot of people left-leaning
participate more in those polls
i think overall given that the the
bodies that
uh conduct them so
it's there could be some hidden numbers
there you know i'm not a pollster i'm
not an expert on this in any sense so
i'm just kind of hypothesizing based
upon what i'm reading and seeing but
um yeah yeah there was one thing that i
postulated way back when when trump won
that election in 2016 which is
i think the one positive i mean depends
on where you are you can take a lot of
positives or no positives whatever
once again i'm not endorsing anybody but
i think the one positive you could take
from having trump as a president is that
a lot more people became involved in and
aware of politics
um and in fact if you look at the
numbers this year it proves that
where you know i think if something like
a 118 million or something like that
people voted um in the 2016 election and
we already have a hundred million
ballots that have been mailed in
so we are almost approaching the numbers
of people voted from the 2016 election
in just early voting alone
which is crazy so you know right there
it does show that people have become
more passionate and more involved
in this country's uh politics yeah um
overall that's a good thing i think
overall it's really a good thing
as long as you're doing your your duty
as an american
citizen to educate yourself before you
vote definitely
because a lot of people treat politics
like sports and yeah i don't think it's
healthy
i i you know i'm not i'm not gonna
reveal like
who i generally vote for like along
party lines but kanye
yeah kanye but regardless like what i do
with
every single race before i vote
i go in and i do my research on
all the main candidates whether that's
democrat
republican sometimes even libertarians
um
i know i'm not voting for green party so
sorry guys i'm not
but um we're using deduction now
uh yeah so now it's 99 clearly
and a half percent of everyone uh
so what i do is i go through and i look
at all of them and then
also having just moved to texas the way
that they run
state elections here is different um so
for example uh the texas supreme court
of the state
uh the every time there's a vacancy
on this on the texas state supreme court
the governor
uh appoints the next person but then
that person comes into the term
uh of the person that they left which
run on six year
uh alternating cycles and so say like
uh you know ruth bader ginsburg for
example just passed
say if she was on a term and say she was
like four years into a six-year term
then uh amy coney barrett would be
appointed
she would then be placed in that
position and then
two years later she'd have to go through
uh like basically an
approval election um they're not very
political but i
there is maybe there's some com i'm too
early to judge it but there might be
some common sense there with like
the idea that okay you're appointed and
then you you still have like a term
limit where after like
six or ten or 20 years or whatever you
have to re-up
uh and it's just it's basically the
people's opportunity to say
yeah you're doing a good job st you know
keep going um
and so there's risk in that obviously
because you turn it over to the public
to decide that sort of thing uh
at a certain point but it's also i liked
how it was balanced between
uh like not just being a complete like
oh let's just pick the most charismatic
politician who will say anything to be a
judge
versus you know this person's gonna
decide for you and you have no choice in
the matter
and so there's a lot of different
interesting there's also like a railroad
commissioner here who's
who's basically the railroad
commissioner yeah it's a
it's a carryover term from uh the
railroad days but basically um
up until the 70s uh when opec became
more powerful as a
as the main cartel that controlled the
oil and gas industry
which by the way people cartels are not
necessarily illegal
cartels are just economic organizations
that control a price
on a product um and so before opec
the texas railroad commission actually
set the standard
uh in many ways for the price of oil and
gas
uh not only nationally but globally and
they still continue to have a lot of
influence in that today
and so that's also an electable position
and i'm
i'm still doing like my my deep dive
into that and it's history but like that
one struck me as a little
like hey maybe maybe this person
shouldn't be elected um
you know because what you need in there
is a really good economist
that's what you need you don't you don't
want to be like
electing the the head of the federal
reserve you know
you don't want that to be like a
political position you want this yeah
it's just tricky with those positions of
power
you know well of course i mean there's
always a balance but
i just deep diving into that's been
really interesting moving from
california to texas and seeing how the
uh the structures are different
you know it's uh well i guess you know
we'll know once this podcast comes out
but supposedly
texas might actually go uh blue this
year which would be
rather a big change of pace for that
that stage oh
i i think that's a little bit more
conjecture
than he might be led to believe i mean
maybe i'm dead wrong
but like i mean right now there's three
million
3.6 million votes have been counted in
texas and
biden's ahead it's 54 biden 45
trump right now right now as of this
podcast recording right the second
that's accounting early voting all right
so guys sure it's not a live podcast
if you haven't noticed i i have to i
keep have to remind you guys
this is yeah actually a point on that
though
if uh if people would like to see live
podcasts it's something we've been
discussing we might start doing them
as soon as this year probably early next
year we're going to start doing them
live on corridor digital.com
and then they'll come out like shortly
thereafter on youtube
and then obviously they'll be published
uh on all the audio only platforms
so let us know if that's something you
want to see so
we've generally avoided talking about
politics you know and taking political
stances at this corridor like you won't
see
you know you won't see candidate
endorsements or anything like that on
our instagram
um no hell no we're even pretty soft
about even just like the general stuff
um you know i obviously this is this is
a setup question i'm you know starting a
discussion here but
jake why is that why do we avoid
politics
well um it's first of all it's just not
it's not our sphere of expertise
right like we're just we're just men who
live our regular lives and we you know
we make videos and that's got its own
little weird
niche and all these different inherent
sort of characteristics to it and
i try to focus on that i mean my basic
philosophy is like
do what you can with what you have
around you and don't
try to don't really worry about the rest
you know focus on your sphere of
influence
try to make that sphere of influence as
the best thing that it can possibly be
and then just move on because that's all
if everyone does that
then guess what we live in a really
awesome world you know
but you that just my whole philosophy is
like
you know if it if it doesn't if it
doesn't uh
if it's not infringing on your freedoms
then you know i'm pretty libertarian in
that sense
um then i'm pretty cool with people
doing whatever they want
um but you know by and large i think
that comes from that philosophy which is
just like
focus on yourself make yourself better
because that will make everyone around
you and everything around you better
um and and it's sort of the inward out
philosophy rather than looking outward
and saying
why what can i get from the world it's
more saying like what can i build within
myself and then
and then give to the world or bring into
the world rather
obviously you know there's your own
inherent benefits that you get that
comes with that but i feel like that's
just a good philosophy for anyone to
have
and so i don't i don't necessarily
approach anything differently
um and you know by and large like
sam was saying a few podcasts back like
maintaining
uh corridor digital as a place where
people can come
be entertained enjoy stories focus on
new interesting things that we're
working on and that we're doing and have
that be the focus of
of what our content is i think is
just there's a there's a need for that
too and there's a place for that too
and there's a lot of pressure in today's
day and age to want to
oh you have to have an opinion about
everything you have to have and it's
like
that's just not true not only as a young
person like
what you say you're 18 19 20 years old
you've been thinking about real world
issues for what maybe
three four years you know it's like you
just
you just don't have it all up here in
order to like fully examine the
the full extent of everything that's
going on in the world
and have a perfect solution for it and i
and i and i think upholding people to
that standard is completely unrealistic
and then also like the whole idea of
judging people for which presidential
candidate they vote for i think is is
heinous
in in a way like there's a lot of
pragmatic reasons for why you might vote
for biden or why you might vote for
trump or why you might vote for somebody
else
and i think just respecting the fact
that
people can have different things that
are important to them
and you can you can look at that and you
can say okay
that's great as long as you're educating
yourself about
it as long as it matters to you and as
long as it's
you know you're going about it in a way
that's not destructive to others
then i think it's a you know you can't
judge somebody for that
yeah i mean the majority of people are
good people and they want the best
for one another and you know everybody
has their story
and their context and you can't just
ignore that you know regardless of who
somebody votes for you need to know why
if you're going like you can't just pick
you vote for this person i'm going to
judge you because of that because you're
you know what yadda yadda
right it's you know everybody has
context and it's just
especially now like the human mind's not
set up to
understand that there's like you know
millions of individuals
all with different backstories you know
here in america and uh
you know anytime you treat a group of
people as one monolithic
entity that all share the same ideology
you're really
you're really being unfair um because
that's not how people work
and you know as human beings we have the
need to do that we have the need to put
a symbol or a name on something and then
everything just matches my
category now you know that i put put
that in but that's not how the real
world works and i think
if you're going to in good faith talk
about politics
you need to have that nuance but there's
really not a lot of room for nuance when
it comes to entertainment and that's
kind of where the problem is
you know when it comes to talking about
politics yeah
and the last thing i think just to
button that up is is
if you are out judging others
on a topic and and you yourself
aren't like really educated in that
topic i think
i don't think that's fair you know like
there's been a lot of situations this
year where
i think like things have become
aggrandized or simplified and people
have just
you know taken to the taking to the
torches and flames about it
without necessarily understanding well
what what is the context here what is
the law here what is the rational basis
for why things are done this way
am i understanding that am i aware of
that or do i just write it off as like
well the whole system's corrupt and so
it's all wrong
because that's not how that's not how
this that's not how anything gets better
you know there's a there's an
interesting parallel so i listened to uh
the dan carlin podcast in the the fall
of rome
how the death throes of the old republic
which is a great title for a podcast
great one yeah yeah and uh
you know one of the parallels that i you
know really drew to today it's you know
this
idea of mob justice right yeah and
sometimes you know it's like
it's just you know justice isn't being
served so sometimes you just got to get
a mop together to make it happen it's
like
here's the thing here's the thing so
yeah so there was an
unwritten rule i mean i guess it was
probably written actually in rome
which is that you never uh so basically
as a general you'd have your legionaries
yeah and when you're a general when you
come into rome you don't take your army
with you
uh basically there's an unwritten rule
that never
ever do you ever bring in your military
to make something happen in rome like
your military
that's all for conquering other lands
but in rome no never ever
it was an offense to the gods that's how
they exactly yeah
sure enough just before caesar i think
it was i can't remember the guy's name
um yeah i might worry about it the other
guy the guy just before season yeah
yeah sure enough was like you know what
these senators are corrupt they're
killing people left and right you know
they were they're
like senators were like literally
assassinating their rivals the people
that are trying to stand up against them
because they're turning they're
basically a bunch of you know corrupt
bribed officials that were making power
players there's all a bunch of you know
house of cards frank underwood's types
yeah and there was no police and there's
no police yeah
yeah you're just like screw this i i'm
going to march on the city screw it i'm
going to have a coup you know i'm going
to kick them all out i'm going to make
myself emperor because i'm going to fix
these problems
right and you know all those good
intentions are great but then he
established that hey guess what
it is now no longer sacred you can
finally march in the city and
if you basically if you break those
sacred rules if you
if you go and you do the thing that you
never should do even if it's quote
unquote for good
it's not it's not going to stick because
now the next person can say well i guess
you know they march in the city because
it's bad well guess what things are
still bad so now i'm going to march in
the city which is kind of what happened
with julius caesar
and then sure enough everybody just kept
assassinating each other and rome fell
apart
that was the guy that caesar was married
to his daughter right yes
yes yeah exactly yeah but caesar kind of
did the same thing he made himself
emperor and once again you know he's
like
he tried to do good things to a certain
degree you know you can look at he's
also had to you know things that weren't
good
um but you could argue that caesar was
actually an emperor for the people but
the thing is the moment caesar died
there was nothing like there's nothing
in place to continue
that benevolence you know it's he
instead he just established hey guess
what you can murder
and kill your way into power and it's
totally okay if your reason's good
yeah it's not like caesar was benevolent
like so
yeah santa did all those things because
i mean and then he declared himself
dictator for life
yeah so you were only supposed to be
dictator for 10 years before that
yeah but basically what i'm trying to
get to here is like you know so if you
turn it to like modern times like with
mob mentality right even if it's quote
unquote for a good cause
you know even in quote unquote you're
canceling somebody who deserves it if
you're if you're doing it the wrong way
you're setting an awful president it's
not it's not it's not a long-term
solution it will not last it's not how
you
actually fix things if you fix things
you have to do it in a good way you have
to fix things the appropriate way you
can't just take a shortcut
because in real life the ends do not
justify the means that's not how
humanity works
yeah yeah it's easy to forget that
totally
if if more people from all walks of life
applied that
we'd be a lot better off like yeah and
not like we're not
you know this this i i still think this
country is a wonderful place to live
um oh certainly but uh yeah obviously
we we we need to get some uh some things
sort of back on track and done right but
you know that's that's
that will always be true no matter what
what city you live in what state what
country
there always be room for improvement 100
yeah
yeah it's fascinating stuff but well to
come full circle on that question uh
the reason we stay out of politics on
these channels is because
there are plenty of other sources if you
want
to get into that that's true yeah that's
true everything in the world
does not have to be political you know
yeah
you should definitely vote and do all
your business but
it doesn't necessarily mean that
everything you create or produce or get
involved with has to have some sort of
political agenda associated with it to
make it meaningful because
there are things in life that are
meaningful that are not related to
politics
so yep yeah i feel like that's
best way i can sum that up yeah you know
and it's honestly politics
come from your human philosophy and so
i'd rather speak to human philosophy
and then let people have that naturally
bloom into whatever it's going to be
you know versus me telling them like
here's the end result
and i'm gonna let you figure out how to
get there
and it's not like um just being really
involved in politics or
having very strong opinions about it uh
also sets a stage to solve all the
world's problems i think that's a that's
a
that's a thing that people need to sort
of get away from philosophically as well
is this idea that like
oh well government's supposed to fix
everything right
like you know what about what about
yourself what about those around you
what about
what about your responsibility to others
you know that all
of that stuff comes first fundamentally
and then
you know that other stuff is you know
it's going on but like
there's nothing there's another opinion
strong opinions without action are
kind of akin to gossip you know at a
certain point yeah
where it's like you're just talking so
yeah the action is super important and i
you know here's last thing here and then
we can move on to something else
but sure this is this is the thing that
strikes me as a big challenge and i
i wish more people would be aware of
this but
people live up to your expectations this
isn't a thing like it's proven with
psychology studies it's proven with
many different things but like like they
for example did a study where it's like
they had a classroom and they told the
teacher like this kid is really smart
so you know they're gifted uh enjoy this
kid
not so smart not gifted they're gonna be
a problem child
of course both of those introductions
were completely you know like
those are misleading things like there's
nothing special about either kid
sure enough the kid that was the teacher
thought was uh that was expecting to be
gifted
turns out to do better and the kid that
the teacher expected to do worse did
worse
so people live up to their expectations
now
if we are constantly expecting
whether it's a government official or
the police or the teachers or any other
kind of you know
government job like if we are or even
not even that anything if we are
constantly expecting people to be
like [ __ ] or fuck-ups you know what
these things
well guess what people are going to live
up to that expectation
yeah and that's that's one of the really
hard things is how can you be critical
of something or how can you impact
change
but how can you do it in a way that sets
an expectation
that like you know i can appreciate you
or i can see you doing a good job or
like
these are the things that you did great
on like you know where's that positive
expectation where can we expect
you know our we're going to expect our
utility company to do a great job with
our utilities
where can we expect the police to do a
great job with policing etc
so that people can live up to these
positive expectations because right now
everybody expects government employees
to be really really bad at something and
that's kind of then what happens is
people live up to those expectations
and that's just something that like you
know that that's complete like that
matches for any political ideology on
any side of the aisle it's just how
people are you know everybody expects
the worse of whatever it is that they're
criticizing
yeah and it's really hard to get
positive change if that's how you're
approaching it
that's a good point um and and and i've
seen that even in
well like you said i've seen that even
in like my own life
you know um with with my relationships
with people
and you know as we've grown corridor and
stuff i i've i've seen how
my expectations of people and my
uh and that combined with the way that i
am personally i've seen how
that has an effect on others and i think
maybe this is just me being an old man a
bit about it but like
the older i've gotten the more i've
become aware of that
um and i wasn't as much aware of it when
i was younger
um i don't know if that's just me
personally or if that's kind of true for
more people
but um that's uh
that's like in my opinion that's one of
the most important things you can do
which is why i'm saying it all goes back
to me for uh
focus on building yourself and making
yourself better and then having that
have a have an
effect on the world around you um
because that's
the most yeah i just i don't know i feel
like that's the best thing you can do
and you have direct control over it too
um
so yeah um interesting though it'll be
interesting to listen to this in like
four days
and uh and see how see how this all went
down
yeah um well should we uh
do you want to talk about what we just
shot in texas we shot a really cool
project over there yeah there's plenty
to talk about with that because that's
that was uh that was a big week and a
half there yeah and we should also give
people an update on functional
filmmaking because that's
been going on and i know that let's do
that right now we're almost done with
the script okay
each all the scripts are like somewhere
between 70 to 90
here they're gonna be all wrapped up in
the next couple days and we are shooting
next week aka like the ninth or so yeah
we begin filming yeah we begin filming
on
the 11th yeah we prep set on the 11th
carmichael has a court date on the 12th
maybe i shouldn't say that out loud but
i just did it
it's probably mild it was probably yeah
it's probably parking violations
yeah basically yeah and then we filmed
it
chemical has an electric bike he doesn't
have a car
i'm not going to say what it's for but
it is minor
yeah anyways we only called him michael
until he gets his car um
by the way sam you are roboting out just
a little bit still okay
it's probably just fine because i'm
recording on my end so don't worry about
it
okay okay uh and then yeah and then the
week of the 16th we go into
like most of the photography we're gonna
start clint's
episode uh next week and then the week
after that we go into most photography
we're trying to get everything in the
can before thanksgiving
and then uh we are trying to
this is still a little bit dependent on
how the episodes are are coming in posts
but
we're trying to release the first
episode on december 14th
and then run once a week um
sorry the first class on december 14th
each class has a few
sort of parts to it um and then run each
class
uh each week for the following uh one
two
three four five six weeks plus a bonus
uh some extra curriculum uh stuff
yeah the week of the 25th of jul january
so
yeah that's the update on functional
filmmaking for everyone who backed it
um i hope you guys are super excited
because what we're doing with it is
we're shooting it and approaching it a
little bit differently than any other
content that we've
made before this isn't just like hey
let's just go back to our youtube
tutorials
this isn't like you know this is it's
gonna have its own sort of look and feel
and style to it
um and i'm super excited to see what
people think of it
yeah yeah and i'm just gonna we don't
have official dates for this
but my predictions for son of a dungeon
are we finish filming functional
filmmaking finish filming functional
filmmaking
yeah um over the next two to three weeks
here
end of november rolls around green
screen
studio built in in in uh
in the studio we have the three wall in
the floor studio built before the end of
the year
yeah when we come back in january we can
basically start busting that out right
away
yeah that's a great idea because i think
the
all the creative stuff on for the show i
think is pretty much figured out we have
a lot of
all the technical approaches with photo
scanning and doing all the green screen
filming is kind of figured out here
um the only thing left to do is yeah
basically build that part of the studio
out that we need
and then play some d how wide
how wide do you want that to be
dude i'm thinking well okay it's gonna
be a party of three to four people
yeah so ideally it's gonna be just big
enough where we can get some shots with
four people on it
um so i mean what does that mean like at
least
at least like 15 feet wide minimum
maybe even a little bit more yeah i'm
just thinking like 15 20.
we're gonna paint the floor and paint
the wall for sure yeah and do a quarter
wall and then add like an extra wall uh
that juts out so we can have a corner
okay you know do the little ramps on the
floor for those smooth
edges yeah something like that
you know make it kind of legit so that
way we can uh really get some awesome
shots on it and future proof ourselves
for
all further green screen effects i was
gonna have uh
guillermo make a few uh like minor
do a few minor things in studio four so
maybe he can build that quarter ramp
wall that makes the infinity line
uh you can do some cool skateboard half
pipe tricks and then we can do one wheel
tricks on it
i mean the other option see how high you
can ride up the wall
yeah you just take a massive chunk of
one of the walls just do like a 25
to 30 foot wide yeah section and just
have one wall like that because that
would be wide enough to do
some stuff it's just the only thing you
lack there is you can't you can't like
move the camera around a lot you can't
like pan
and so the corner allows you to do like
really intense 3d moves
and i think we should do a corner yeah
yeah i think that might be better
plus so texas i mean we're talking about
whatever we're talking about
i'm not like i don't know i want any
helmet on the topic here that's okay
i don't want to talk about this texas
trip because there's a lot of funny
stuff
and it was really enjoyable and yeah it
was kind of a big deal because we shot
like the biggest commercial we've ever
filmed it was our most expensive
per minute thing we've ever shot i think
yeah
yeah lifeline i think doesn't meet that
lifeline was expensive but it was also
no no no no no no no no
it was also hours long yeah yeah yeah
this is only
three minutes yeah i can do the math
actually okay
i think it was the most expensive thing
per minute we've ever shot and
the best part about it was that i think
we didn't just sort of absorb ourselves
in a traditional industry machine we
took
i think we had a very healthy balance of
some of the best parts of the
traditional industry
uh like that gaffing and electric crew i
mean nico you were the director of
photography so you tell me but i thought
they killed it
yeah they did a great job i mean there's
things that i know now
going back in that i just make some
minor adjustments to like with some of
the type of lights i'd pick but i'm not
super well versed in you know like
putting together a grip truck and a gaff
truck you know like yeah
so they brought good gear and the guy
worked with me really well um
brad did as well as uh a little context
yeah actually let's back it up for a
second okay we went down to san antonio
to film with the black rifle coffee guys
and we filmed their black rifle
or black friday commercial yeah
basically
and they did they just have they just
had a partnership with uh that
came through with bass pro shops they've
been working on for a while so the
coffee is now in the bass pro shops
exactly and so this is a commercial for
that it's so it's like uh
we got to film at a giant bass pro shop
in san antonio
and it's basically just a
nutty huge action sequence
we called we called it zero black friday
because you know they're all military
dudes
and the piece starts with these like
tactical guys going in to break into
this place
and it turns out it's coffee and then it
gets really goofy from there
yeah now it's worth pointing out that
you know this is this is intended to be
like a tv level commercial
and going into it we wanted to show them
that we can make tv level stuff you know
we make youtube videos we do that all
the time we can make cool action scenes
etc but
in terms of like that polish that you
get with a tv commercial
you know that's not something that we
really do all that often and
you know in addition to that you know
this is a thing where jake is in texas
he's producing
a full on like full crude production
which is not something that you've done
very often jake
you've done it a little bit here and
there but in terms of this you haven't
done very often
yeah and sam and i are rolling in and
usually once again usually it's one or
the other because the other person kind
of stays back to
you know run the studio and the other
person goes out for a project in this
case we're both going there
and at least for me you know i think we
all have the same idea but we want all
wand to show that we can
we can do what it takes to run a true
professional production
yeah we can be very very professional
the whole time
everyone acts with the
no smiling professional there's no
smiling
there's no goofing off there's no like
sticking our hands into aquariums and
getting hit by giant fishes
you know it's we're talking like we're
talking like
we show up we got our suits we got our
ties all the way up
we're running out of business now what
we actually mean by professional is that
we show up
we have the shots planned and more most
importantly is we know how to work with
the crew
um because we had like a crew of 50
people on set
and sam myself and jake are basically
sitting at the top of this crew
running this thing and if you've never
led a group of 50
specialized professionals before let me
tell you it's definitely a new
experience if you haven't done it
yeah and uh you know it i think it's one
of the things was like you know sam and
i
you know we've had rush we've had
lifeline and
both of those really contributed a ton i
guess to our education as filmmakers
and jake i'm not sure if you've ever
really seen us operate
in that capacity of like full set
professional filmmakers before like
we've been on
sets together but ever since we shot
lifeline i don't think we've been on
this kind of a set together
yeah and so jake you know jake kind of
put the pieces in place and sam and i
stepped in
and you know once again like your our
perception in what directing is has
changed over the years our perception on
what director of photography is has
changed over the years
and we rolled in we tried to really
apply all this knowledge we have and i
feel like we did you know we walked away
in my opinion like having aced it like
the crew was saying they had a great
experience
uh the black rifle coffee guys they had
a great experience i had a great
experience you guys i think had a great
experience
so all in all like what we set up to
accomplish outside of the quality of the
piece hopefully the piece is good you
won't we don't know until it's
edited but in terms of the experience
the experience was like
it was really fulfilling as one of those
things it's like we walked in and we're
like yeah
we did it we actually ran a professional
suit shoot like
i've been the director of photography on
a youtube video but i've never done it
on a
real shoot with like real gear in a real
bass pro shop
you know yeah and and navigated my way
through it and sam navigated his way
through directing and jake navigated his
way through being an executive producer
and we walked away from it having having
done it
yeah no there was a moment there because
i also added the thing
which is a kind of a weird niche thing
that
most people don't know what an assistant
director is but like well the director
is talking creative stuff with
so niko's director is an assistant
director or [ __ ] director i can't
tell
it's because he has the director then
you have the [ __ ] director who
works it's the [ __ ] director
um but so so the the function of it is
and it's a good it was a good role for
me in this project because i
produced it and then um you know
producers make a really good assistant
directors
in my opinion because i've worked with
you guys a ton too obviously we've been
working together for 10 years now so
you know i understand kind of what your
what your ticks are and what your
you know strengths and weaknesses are
and i'm able to sort of like
make sure that the crew is is
participating and facilitating all those
things
to the best of their ability and i but i
realized about a week before
i've never assisted directed a set of
this size much less with a bunch of
people who have been doing uh
like traditional industry work for way
longer than i have
and so there was a moment a week before
was like do i even remember how to ad
the imposter syndrome starts to set in
yeah but you know what i figured it out
after like
two hours on the first day and i was
like oh
it's just standing there as if
i was i the way that i was approaching
it was just like okay
if i was gonna direct this shot what
would i do
okay uh what's our framing okay what's
our action
okay what's our lighting and then i
would just talk to each one of those
department heads
and then make sure that sam had
communicated his
creative information first make sure
that you had communicated
your creative information to the camera
department and the lighting department
and then you know and then just step
back
yeah well and and don't forget hands on
your hips slight scowl tapping your foot
making people a little anxious because
that's actually looking at your watch
yeah yeah you have to do that like you
have to be
kind of an edgy mean guy as an assistant
director and
maybe you know i granted there's sure
there's nice assistant directors out
there but really like
they're not working you're not working
yeah
that's the role i want an assistant
director i'm gonna get you
jake i want to get you the loudest
pocket watch
yes that has ever existed that each time
you take it out it's on a little
chain each time you flip it open it's
like clicking and ticking
so loud that everyone around you for
like a good like
30 40 people
each time somebody would give me a time
estimate i'd say hey how far out are you
on that thing
i would literally flip my watch over and
i'd hit start
and i'd start timing them brad noticed
brad though the lighting gathered no
no we're doing this after like a few
times and he's like are you timing me
and he's like and then he was like how
have i been doing
and i was like actually you've been
ahead uh every time cool
which is very rare that's a good answer
by the way even if he wasn't quite ahead
it's a really good like yeah i'll keep
working fast
yeah no he was though he was giving me
really good estimates
and so i just started doing that with
everybody and uh it was just kind of a
fun little game that i was playing in my
own head
we should put that in the next top 10
games books
guess how long it takes somebody to do
something and then time it and see if
you're right
but you can't use a watch you have to
count the seconds
yeah well i found out i've been googling
the loudest pocket watches
and okay apparently pin pallet pocket
watches
the it's a special mechanism that is
incredibly like
present and loud like i don't know like
a cricket
great yeah i'll throw it out there
that's what we do
you might see it sometime soon all right
um
yeah but it was good i like filming with
those guys because
um the black rifled coffee guys because
you know
they already film a lot of videos they
they know how to be on camera
and do that whole thing you know they're
not like all like trained actors
um but you know like matt and jt are
like
super charismatic you know logan is a
really great like
action hero type and evan basically
doesn't act
instead he just like shows up and then
like he it's always like a meta
performance like he knows he's being
filmed
and like kind of intentionally like
[ __ ] things up
in a way like that's kind of funny and
so you just kind of know
that that's gonna happen and make sure
you you embrace it and it works
but um i think more than anything else
like i like working with them because
i kind of think some of the military
experience translates to the set in the
sense of like
them they're being on time they respect
the hierarchy of the set you know they
um
like they they they always give like a
full commitment
to a shot and they don't they're tough
dudes yeah yeah
you know what i mean like there's a
really intense work ethic
that they bring to it which is really
great to work with because
you know we're filming at night filming
until 7am sometimes
yeah and it gets very taxing and just
being able to like all right
suck it up let's power through this
let's yeah do it as best as we can
um like i don't know it's it's it's
always a pleasure
pleasure filming with them because of
that one of the things that like
that i observe like because we're going
into this we want to
bring in our strengths in how we operate
a crew as
corridor which doesn't always translate
into how a big crew operates
and so as you know there's a thing that
we tried to bring together in this piece
where
we had our crews but they were very much
set up to work with us as we were
kind of nimbly going through our shots
and doing the things that we do
and uh you know one of the one of the
things that stood out to me is kind of
like
a thing that i haven't ever experienced
on another commercial set that i really
liked on this set
and i think it's also a testament to
like the little bits of wisdom you pick
up that aren't you can't learn in film
school
is uh you know all the black rifle
coffee guys liked
looking at the playback on the camera
you know and it's because
you know i'm the same way i'm not a
trained actor like usually after i do a
couple takes i need to watch myself to
see
how it's actually looking because i
don't know how i look like i'm not that
good of an actor
and uh you know so you get a shot i
noticed they kind of wander over to the
camera i'm like okay pull playback
and after about like that happening two
or three times i like i turned the
camera crew like
after every shot that they're in pull up
playback and have it queued up
because they want to see it and it's
just one of the things like it suddenly
flips a switch from it being like a
commercial professional
shoot to shooting with your friends and
it's not the same as having it on video
village
it's like it's literally they walk up
they stand over your shoulder on the
camera you point at the screen you play
it back and you all kind of
chuckle about it or talk about it and
you're right there you get the reactions
and like for a moment like the entire
crew kind of just melts away
it's just you and a couple buddies
checking out the shot and then like what
do you gotta do to make it better and
like you know problem solving it
yeah and like that's a vibe that's like
very specific to like a corridor style
shoot
that you don't get on commercial shoots
and like we got to bring it in there and
it stood out to me too and we were
filming with a a kid um
this girl was i think 10 years old that
was doing uh wire work
um acrobatics and stunts and after we
got a shot you know we're laughing about
it you know sam you're laughing about
like it's like the wolf shot or
something like that and you're like
you're you know laughing and talking
about it and the other guys are laughing
about and talking about it and she's
kind of standing there
and i'm like hey do you want to see the
shot and she's like yeah and so i sit
down and i hit playback
and like that's something that you can't
do as a camera operator on a union set
you know i mean you could you know you'd
probably get angry at you but it's like
it'd kind of be like not okay whereas in
this case like screw it like
we can wait 30 seconds while i show the
girl with this cool shot she just did
she wasn't an actress she hadn't really
done this stuff before
and like later on we did another shot
and she immediately walked up like can i
see it it's like sure and you know
one second guys and i show it to her and
it's like that's the kind of stuff
that i really enjoy with filmmaking and
i never want to lose that
yeah yeah i totally agree i totally
totally agree i mean it helps too when
like the executive producers of the
commercial
are like the actors in it you know yeah
and then the executive producers of the
production are the director
the ad and the dp yeah i mean
i mean but but seriously it's like it's
it's like big but
like just small enough where there was
that freedom to
you know and i don't want to say treat
it like a casual
shoot with friends but like not lose
those core elements of what filming
videos with friends is like where it's
like
here's you know some shots you know you
film them and and
people do their thing and everyone's
like not feeling it it's like oh what if
we did this and like
everyone like it's it's a set where you
know
there's there's this kind of big group
of people it's like almost like 10 to 12
people
almost that all can still like pipe in
you know and it's like no one's like oh
better not speak up you know it's like
you know jake you're throwing out stuff
nico you're throwing out stuff
all the black rifle guy coffee guys were
you know
matt cairns you know everyone who was
like in that like inner circle there it
was still just like a
corridor shoot so to speak where yeah
you know
you know there's no like it's not like
there's a penalty for
throwing out advice or like an idea
yeah we struck that good mix of like you
know there is
you know you have to respect everybody's
roles on the set like sam is the
director so
if you're going to give direction to an
actor usually you should either give it
directly to sam
or get it cleared by sam to give it to
the actor but that doesn't mean that you
can't provide an idea whereas you know
once you get on a traditional set
if you're a camera operator you
shouldn't be giving the director
anything
on a traditional set but you know what
then you miss out like hey guys we just
tweaked the shot a little bit it'd be
great for my angle you know it's like
you miss out on that stuff
you gotta hope that like the dp catches
it or something like that totally yeah
totally and there are to be fair there
are traditional sets that do
run that way effectively um yeah but
they're just
they're they're guys who have been doing
it for for 30 40 years
and they've been working with the same
crew and they all understand exactly
what those little unwritten rules are
amongst themselves as well and uh but
that's just not how we came up
you know yeah we so for us to apply
ourselves into that medium
exactly to the way that it's done at the
highest level in that way wouldn't
necessarily make our videos the best
that they can be so
there's you know we i feel like maybe we
were
overly critical of the traditional
industry back in the day probably
because we're
maybe you know just uh not very
experienced in it
yeah exactly um and and a little bit of
experience
uh comes with a little bit of wisdom and
uh i feel like
there's just you know there's some
things that
are done well uh you know like like
set hierarchies making sure that
especially in the a.d role i was
noticing like okay
i don't one thing it's my job to make
sure that i don't end up with a pa
nation that's running around trying to
do everything
right so how do you do that you you have
to go through
whoever the other principal party is for
for whatever line of communication you
need to get to
um and making sure that that was
constantly being done
uh because sometimes um if you're too
lazy fair about it then uh you know then
you get this cluster
f and it's not and then that's not any
good either
um so yeah just just understanding what
the strengths are of
what the traditional industry has and
what they can bring on board but also
making sure that
we're preserving like the creative space
that we know we're good at
um is super important yeah and then
the one thing though the one traditional
thing
that we didn't do on this shoot and i
feel like the shoot
really proves like why we're
i feel like we're kind of right okay let
me guess let me guess i'm not gonna say
i'm just gonna make a hand sign
is it this yes
yes getting rid of that god damn
clapboard yes every time you're like all
right here we go
scene three take whatever take but it's
like shut up just like
hit it you know it's like but but here
there's so many
it's like that one action like let me
explain
all the problems or things that just
like suddenly
you now have to compensate for yeah yeah
first off you're adding a
good 5 to 15 seconds
on the front of every single shot now
we're shooting hundreds of shots
you know shooting hundreds of shots you
start adding that up
you know at the end of the day you lose
like a straight up half hour
of just people messing with the
clapboard right in front of your
camera and not only that but like little
things like oh now suddenly it's like oh
someone is going to hit a mark you know
you're going to pull focus to a mark or
like an action is going to happen there
everyone gets their cameras set you know
everyone gets the focus dialed in
boom clapboard comes in oh you lose all
this and all the people on cameras need
to refocus to this
thing and then they leave and then they
refocus back to you know it's like
that adds time that adds error all that
stuff
um i mean yeah what it gives you is like
a visual cue
as to like a sync but you know what
you're using these little wireless time
code boxes
that are working pretty freaking well
they work for everything
i mean yeah they could mess up and
that's like a redundancy thing i guess
having a clapboard but
it's almost like i don't know it worked
yeah it worked we didn't mess up yeah
it's like i would rather
yeah we've gone so long without shooting
with clapboards now that like
i'm kind of okay handling the fallout if
there's an issue with you know like with
the sounds thing it's like well let's
just figure out
using a different fallback method
whether it's scratch audio track or it's
like you're you know
date and time and just edit with what
you got and then finagle the audio
afterwards
yeah you do an audio waveform sync
because all these cameras have
microphones on them too so it's like
it's possible there's no i don't know
i'm so happy we didn't
have to do that for this shoot because i
don't yeah it's just it's just like it's
like a time sink and like
everyone's primed and ready and then
this thing goes in and like maybe i
guess certain actors or like
makes people feel like more serious or
primes people you know it's like all
right here's the shot here we go like
you know that's that's what people said
but you know what i think they're wrong
because you know what it gets people set
and then you go
all right everybody ready camera's set
rolling a speed b speed c speed okay
here we go like right then
everybody's getting set you know those
runners on the starting block they're
they're getting ready
right and then action you know three two
one go and then you go like
that's that's that hypes me up you know
see that's why i always like to yell
three two one action
i was like i'm just like here we go like
i have to set the bar for like energy
you know what i mean before people go
into a take so i have to scream it
yeah yeah it's like red lead us in by
google you're standing by
it's cool it hypes you up and then it's
like all right and
scene three take one one
it's like get out of here no
we need like you need like someone like
hulk hogan
or someone to operate the clapboard if
yeah because if
it's if it's like it's like a it's like
a you know techno song or
you know an electronic music song where
it's like a drum fill like put up a bit
of a bit of it
you know that's that's what you're
calling out yeah you know you're
building you're building
and you don't want some freaking like
two-bit chump going like yeah
[Laughter]
yeah seriously now
obviously if you have an editor who's
not not going to be on your set has no
idea what footage is where like then you
got to label it somehow sure you know
there's
there's times to use clapboards don't
get me wrong but
if you can if you can set up the system
not to do it it sure is nice
it's it's nice just directly filming the
shot you want and like
no no little man to stop and give up
like wait i haven't
put my clapboard in the shot yet right
let alone like feel sleep and then you
gotta do it afterwards and just uh
[Laughter]
you know it's like they have to slip in
and they have to they have to
hope they're not interrupting the take
you know it's like you're filming a take
and then the person's like we didn't
slate it and so they're like trying to
feel like right when the scene's over
and say
that tail slate right before like
everyone gets cut but it's like in the
moment
right in between everyone stops acting
yeah and everybody
and they have to somehow like rush into
that little micro moment
we should pay somebody just a tail slave
an entire shoot
every time you're gonna say god they
just have to guess before the scene is
actually cut
yeah you know nothing's worth mentioning
we ran three cameras for almost the
entire shoot we ran a camera a b camera
and a c camera
which means that if you're gonna slate
for that you have to make sure all three
cameras can see it
yeah at the same time that's what i'm
saying it would have come it just
compounds
everything yeah not only that but on the
money side of the production that's
sam you're saying that's an extra half
hour that you lose
and you're right and a 10 hour 12 hour
day that is probably about an extra half
hour now extrapolated at over four days
so now that's
two full hours plus traditionally you
pay
a second ac to just do that
like a second 400 bucks or something
like that a day yeah yeah like a second
second ac you know you're probably
talking like three to four hundred bucks
so it's four days commercial it's around
twelve hundred bucks or so
this is not only fifteen hundred yeah
you plus two hours
two hours of set time maybe set maybe an
hour set time cost you about
three grand two grand something like
that so you're looking at
four thousand dollars spent just get a
slate in there
right at least yeah at least at least
uh so yeah there's a lot of room i'm
just saying
i'm just gonna throw this out there like
if i do the rough math
but having a slate on top of the
obviously we need the personnel for it
i would say just like the time alone
would have probably cost us
about like four to five thousand dollars
in time yeah yeah um
so yeah we bought we bought a ronin s2
gimbal it just came out
for the shoot and that was 999 so we
could about four of those
we could we could have given away four
of those for the same device you want to
use a class board or get five
top of the line gimbals that just you
know
it's like the clap for it's only like 10
bucks it's like ah
not the ones that show the time no no no
yeah
yeah and some of that stuff's really you
get into these really weird
uh like efficiency questions uh
when you're on set like that especially
in the taking on the producer role with
some of that stuff like
yeah yeah there's just some you get to
some of these really wacky outcomes
sometimes
you know there's one there was one
secret weapon that we had on the shoot
that i think
really attribute i mean outside you know
outside of the fact we've worked
together for 10 years bass pro shop
bass pro shop was actually really easy
to work with honestly for all the
corporate things we've worked with yeah
well yeah but
you need a costume or a prop it's just
like oh we need some more camo and
they're like cool and they just run over
to the camo section grab a new outfit
yeah we've saved the tags it's like yeah
fun
but the the one secret tool which is
kind of
boring when you put it out there is the
video board
it's just to whip it out your phone and
you shoot the video once beforehand
because it's so easy to shoot a video on
your phone
and you do that first and then you can
look at the edit back hey this totally
works or totally doesn't work and you
make some you get some new shots
and then you walk into set you're like
oh i have it all planned out
i'm yeah i'm a smart director i have it
all planned out i shot on my cell phone
beforehand
it's true though because you can see how
it cuts together and you can see if you
have the moment that you really need or
not and
then you can confidently make decisions
as as a director to to
you know say we we need this absolutely
or we don't
yeah yeah i mean basically that was yeah
we pre-shot
the whole we shot the whole video before
arriving on set
and so it's like yeah if you figure out
pacing for sure you go like well this
moment needs to be faster or slower or
this moment um
was yeah it's like we don't need this we
cut this out um
but also like you just generally go like
well like
what what are they like how will we
shoot this like what's a cool angle for
this
or you know you you get rid of all those
problems and it's like yeah the
location's different than
you know we filmed a video board in our
studio but um
even still with those i mean like we
knew what i i had
visited the store like ahead of time so
i had a general sense of
like what we could pull off and where
things were um that obviously helped
but um it was kind of like
between nico yeah i mean you know
nico myself you know we're shooting
directing it's like well we already went
through the
through the process once together so on
set it's kind of like
what's the next shot gonna be it's like
oh well we've filmed it already
we just say oh it's the next shot it's
like okay i know exactly what that is
you know we've already done it and so
it's like is it the close-up of this guy
is that a wide shot of this it's like
from there all you got to do is go like
oh well
i guess what where's the closest
approximation in this store
that matches what we've done already um
and it's fast
and it's very i don't know it's
efficient
it also makes people feel like they you
like
everything's being done for an explicit
reason that's already been like thought
about
you know it eliminates i think a lot of
the what is it
i guess you know you're dealing with 40
people
50 people whatever i forget how big the
crew is but
you know you eliminate everyone watching
you trying to figure out your mind
uh like on every shot i think that
builds a lot of doubt within people
yeah it's like all right what are we
gonna do for this shot it's like i don't
know it's like uh how do we wanna do
this it's like if you're doing that
every single take
it's like wait a second have you guys
thought about this at all
like you know you're just winging it
every time it's like i'm good at winging
it don't worry
yeah i mean have good instincts yeah
it's like not
there's lots of ways to get there you
know and smaller shoots like a
like a a beat list or a shot list will
will suffice usually
um but you know that's i think this is
where like
oh the whole thing with like previz and
video boards really comes into play
i mean it's not like we don't have the
freedom to change it when we want to
which we totally did
but um yeah yeah and the funny thing is
like it took us
two hours three hours to shoot the video
board no it took us
we shot it over like three days i think
we
probably honestly spent about somewhere
between five and eight hours
working still pretty good for all things
considered
yeah but the thing is it's like that's
you have to do that
on a shoot like this with this many
people and this many moving parts
because
you don't like yeah as i was saying with
the the clapboard
it's like now suddenly if we're adding
an extra like five
to ten minutes per shot of like
brainstorming it's just yeah things will
grow into a halt
yeah i feel like you know media has kind
of portrayed the directors like
they walk in the sets like my vision i'm
going to have an artistic vision
and like now i think i can safely say
that
being a director is not that i mean
don't get me wrong there is that aspect
of it but
when you're on set as a director your
job is just to be like okay this is the
shot we're getting so you have to stand
there you have to wear this costume the
camera has to go over there
it's like but the shot's already decided
the creative part's done
we're just executing that i'm just
directing the execution
and then some you know part way through
that's like i have idea an idea you know
i have this prop what if i did this
like that's a creative idea let me be a
director and come up with a creative
solution
like that's you know that comes into
play but really
you know being a professional director
is not going on set to be creative
it's going on set just to execute what's
already planned
yeah yeah yeah like understand
understanding the r
the rationale behind the execution yeah
i think is good too
because you know you have to creatively
execute sometimes to get your execution
but
yeah yeah yeah you're not deciding like
what should my actor be feeling in this
moment like that should all be done
before you're on set you know in that
moment yeah and i mean that makes sense
you know when you boil it down you spend
eight hours
you spend all this time with sam sam and
i spent all this time scripting
right and we scripted and scripted and
scripted sam and then
once the script was finally locked then
you went out with nico and and and
matt karens and clint too and you guys
spent
eight hours total going over
that script and turning it into actual
shots
and i mean that's yeah that's necessary
you know because
doing the video board it changed the
script because like we're filming the
video board and like little things start
coming up it's like wait we wrote it
like this but now that we're here like
doing it
it's kind of weird so what if we did it
like in a different order
right and then we shoot it in that new
order and we're like oh actually this
kind of works pretty well so then
after we finish the video board and
before we get to set right we tweak the
script
to match the video board now right yeah
because it's like well we don't want
we don't we don't want to go to set and
go oh oh oh why why is why are we
shooting it like this like oh we're
going to reverse all this stuff later
it's like no no like
just make it nice and easy on paper so
people can read through it
and sit back and watch the set and go
like oh yeah this is
that's happening and that says this is
going to happen here and it's all lining
up like right
yeah that was that was very helpful too
also working with multiple cameras
like i really enjoy working like a b
camera and a c camera especially they're
in the hands like a good operator that
can just get cool shots and you can just
tell them to go get a cool shot
yeah like you're shooting the video
board and you have two cameras getting
an alternate angle
almost every time so every angle in the
video board has two more companion
angles that are just totally different
that you can you know they're cool you
can do whatever you want with them you
never have to use them if you don't want
to but
you're like you're super covered with
like beats and angles and everything
that you need
but that's that's that's where like the
chaos
comes into play there of like well we
can plan this out but then when we have
the actual people performing this stuff
and their stunts it's like things go
slightly differently than you imagine
they would
and so those extra angles basically
allow you to
cut your way through any problem with
like oh well this has to be faster and
they went slower here and blah blah and
you're like oh cool we have all these
angles we'll just like
fake it you know it's like cool well you
know it kind of covers your butt
but then also it just comes down to that
chaos thing of
you know someone there is a better angle
now that we're here
you know this is the shot that we want
for the edit but this
definitely looks better so let's let's
cover the thing we
you know are intending to do and then
let's also get the better version
at the same time yeah i really enjoyed
the puzzle line later
i really enjoyed the puzzle of uh
setting up three cameras and being like
where can i put the lights
where it looks good for every camera and
they aren't in any of the shots
slash the cameras themselves yeah yeah
that's tough i can
manage to make it work yeah well you
know i think that's the beauty of once
again
the video board and like and once again
this stuff seems like super basic once
you
once you've done it but like just the
process of like okay
let's block the actors let's get their
positions figured out
let's get the camera set let's get the
lighting in place
let's walk it again let's figure out
what we need to get this essential okay
cool now everybody can work
all the crews go do your jobs you know
get your stuff tuned up cool now it's
all tuned up let's put the actors let's
do a rehearsal
okay cool you adjust this light it's
battery powered so it's easy and this
light
needs to be adjusted over there but
that's you know it's it's also on the
stand and so light batteries
or light light it doesn't weigh a lot
light you can move that you know it's
like
okay now we're all set and like just
having that process and just rolling
through it every time routine
you know it's a basic process but at the
same time
it takes us it's taken us so long just
to figure out like oh there's the steps
we should do in this order
to make it run smoothly but it makes all
the difference
yeah totally uh
yeah because it's abstract too you know
it's not like it's not like there's a
manual for filmmaking
yeah and every every crew is different
and every shoot is different and right
yeah it's like that's the weird things
like there is a standardized system to
some degree like when you walk up to the
costume person you're like
i need my look one it's like you know or
my first look it's like they know what
you're talking about like so it's a
terminology that's standardized in the
film industry
but that said there really isn't a
standard for like
your costumes should be organized
exactly this way or your costume books
we made this way
or the way we'll be doing costume
changes is like this like there's no
standard for that you're just
just always problem solving a new
problem all the time
and maybe it's a similar problem to one
that you know previous costume designer
has had and you've got some wisdom on
how to address it but
it's still brand new stuff all the time
that's what makes it fun yeah yeah
definitely
problem solving on on that note guys uh
my kids are getting riley over here okay
and some food for the fam here
gotta close the day out strong here on
election night
yeah you know start to start inside
then i'll vote there's a little bit of
time left
awesome all right well we'll always
we'll all be listening to this when you
guys are listening to it
and uh it'll be a great uh look back
do you guys want money on the outcome of
the election oh i'm looking at it it
looks like binding's going to win this
yeah i got a dollar a dollar up
biden wins anybody want to take me on
that i'll take you out a dollar all
right
jake you're betting against it okay yeah
i'm gonna adjust i'm gonna adjust it
it's a beer once the pandemic's over
either i buy you a beer you buy me a
beer
okay we we don't have to wait until the
pandemic's over i can just use that's a
whole other conversation of when that
happens
all right all right all right virtual
shake
all right there you have it there you
have it
all right thanks for watching the
podcast all right play us out
[Music]
goodbye everybody bye